vision and the other one Economic
Security and I want to comment on both
the backdrop against which we discussed
that is a world that has changed
dramatically we saw three years of
Crisis after crisis
as you all know it culminated in
Russia's war that it Unleashed against
Ukraine and we felt the aftershocks very
painfully Energy prices rising inflation
higher interest rates higher so we are
in a completely different world compared
to 2020 when the mff we're discussing
today was negotiated
of course this also shows in our budget
these world of multiple crises and we
have been using this budget more than
ever to be part of the solution of this
crisis that we saw we have used every
flexibility every possibility of
redeployment we have
re-prioritized our funds for example two
of our largest funds you will know the
fact that we prioritize Next Generation
you in favor of repower EU repower EU
and exact and immediate response to the
energy crisis or take cohesion money
that we reprioritized for the support
for Ukrainian Refugee that was the care
package we designed and of course beyond
that we have mobilized every Euro we
could for Ukraine itself
you know the topics the solidarity Lanes
the humanitarian needs the macro
financial assistance
if you put that in a figure
direct from the EU budget for Ukraine we
allocated so far 30 billion euros and of
course this was initially never foreseen
in our mff
this is why we need to revisit our
budget now
and of course we are fully aware of the
fact that member states were also hit by
the crisis
and after years of large public support
to their economies
it is not time for them for
consolidating their public finances this
we are also aware of and taking all this
into account what I've just described
we come today with a very targeted and a
limited proposal for the absolute must
there are three topics the first is
Ukraine
the second is migration and external
challenges
and the third is preserving our
competitiveness
on Ukraine
here we propose a financial reserve for
the next four years of 50 billion Euro
this includes both loans and grants
The Preserve will provide first of all
perspective for our partners in Ukraine
predictability
and it should also incentivize other
donors to step up to
it will this financial reserve will
allow us really to calibrate our
financial support according to the
evolution of the situation on the ground
because we all know that a war requires
utmost flexibility from us
on migration
the magnitude of migration challenges
today requires us to give
urgent fast responses
we are here proposing to equip Our
member states with financial support
to strengthen the management of our
external border
we need to work more intensively with
our neighborhood to Foster the economic
development to stabilize those countries
we need to enhance our International
partnership
and therefore we need additional budget
for Syrian refugees in Syria in Lebanon
in Jordan and in Turkey
for the southern migration route for the
Western Balkans
for the partners across the world and
also to maintain our capacity to react
to humanitarian crises and natural
disasters
for all of this what I've just described
we are asking for 15 billion Euro one
five
our third priority concerns the
resilience and the competitiveness of
our economy
it is crucial for Europe to have a
technological Edge for the World of
Tomorrow
as you'll recall we've done already a
lot just think of the Net Zero industry
Act and the chips act all reactions on
this topic but we also know that more
needs to be done
and that time is of the essence
and therefore we are creating step
how does it work
we have identified three
sectors of priorities that are critical
to preserve our digital and our
Competitive Edge it is deep Tech it is
clean tech and it is biotech
and then we have efficient funds in our
European budget for projects in these
sectors
but we have limited budgets
you know some of these funds like invest
EU or The Innovation fund and others
Now by creating step
we want to focus These funds on these
priorities
and have them work better together this
creates synergies
and here we are asking for limited
reinforcement
of 10 billion Euro for some of those
funds
because we also want to leverage the
funding capacity of cohesion funds
in order to fund even more these
projects
and this is why we are creating a seal
for the projects that are eligible
but did not receive funding so far
so with this seal we are creating a
pipeline of projects that will be fast
tracked for funding from cohesion
or if I put it in very short terms some
funds have the projects but not the
money cohesion has the money but not the
flow projects so the seal makes both
ends meet
all in all
we expect with leveraging and crowding
enough private Capital this is crucial
that this will result in an investment
capacity of 160 billion Euro for step
finally the new macroeconomics are also
reflected in increasing funding costs
and fixed costs in our budget itself
these issues are also addressed in our
proposal in addition we are coming back
with the own resources topic it is
important to put our budget on a stable
funding trajectory
with this overall revision of the mff we
are asking our 27 member states
to equip us with 66 billion Euro to
deliver on these three priorities I've
just described Ukraine migration and
competitiveness
now to the other topic of Economic
Security
many of the issues that have left led to
the revision of the budget
also have of course revealed inherent
vulnerabilities of our economies
and they have opened our eyes to the
increasing and increasingly complex
risks to National Security and economic
resilience
beforehand I want to make very clear
that Global integration and open
economies are a Force for good for
Europe we need them they are good for
business they're good for
competitiveness they are good for our
economies
that will not change in the future that
is very clear this is a vast majority
for example of all the trade we are
doing
but we also see that the world has
become more contested and geopolitical
and there's a limited set
of key technologies that can be used in
a different and in an aggressive way
and this is why the topic of Economic
Security has become a priority for us
and for many of our partners
we have already done a lot in the last
years
you know the trade defense instruments
for example or we have taken a critical
look at our resilience and dependencies
in certain sectors think of the chips
the clean tech Or the critical raw
materials we have discussed it many
times
but giving the changing nature of the
risks we now need a strategic vision
for how we are going to handle these
risks
and today Europe becomes the first major
economy to set out a strategy on
Economic Security
it builds on three policy strands we
want to promote
we want to protect and we want to
partner
a few words on these three stands the
first is to promote our own
competitiveness
here in Europe we are doing this already
by Investing For example in research to
Horizon Europe you know next Generation
you the Greendale industry plan the
digital transition but also upskilling
our Workforce this is promote the
competitiveness of Europe
the second strand is protect ourselves
from risks that we have identified
this means also that we have to be more
assertive in using the existing tools
you know them it's 5G and 6G security
the foreign direct investment instrument
export controls but also anti-coherion
instruments
and it means working on targeted new
tools for example on outbound investment
outbound investment means we need to
ensure that European companies capital
their knowledge their expertise their
research
is not abused by countries of concern
for military application
so we are working on how to best build
such an instrument and we will propose
an initiative before the end of the year
my final point
we need to partner on Economic Security
this means first and foremost bolstering
our research cooperation with others
it's also about strengthening our trade
relations and Supply chains and
diversify these Supply chains this was
one of the main topics I've discussed in
my trip last week to Latin America for
example here on the free trade
agreements that we are pushing forward
but also for example a common project
under global gateway like on renewable
um energy like green hydrogen or for
example critical raw material
partnership
so with today's strategies we're
ensuring that we have a clear set
objectives principles processes to
prevent and mitigate these risks as they
emerge many things
yeah yeah the mic is behind
thanks the economic security strategy I
know is country agnostic however reading
between the lines and the fact that you
first announced it when you give your
keynote speech on China I'm wondering
how much was the Chinese I guess
economic practice and security concerns
how large did that feature in in your
thinking when this was being put
together thanks
so indeed it is country agnostic our
Economic Security strategy and
um with China for example we have a
large part where we work very closely
together and cooperate together and that
is the fight against climate change
we should not forget that China is
emitting 30 of the global greenhouse gas
emissions so it's on our vast interest
on both sides to work very closely
together and to cooperate in this field
then we have the whole economic field
and here I want to emphasize again the
vast majority of trade and economic
relations with countries and also China
is um the business as usual if I would
like to frame it that way so for example
we're discussing a Level Playing Field
we're discussing access to the market
we're discussing how to balance the
relationship but
um this is uncomplicated
in Economic Security we're looking at a
limited small set of cutting-edge
Technologies
and here we want to make sure that they
do not enhance the military capacities
of some countries of concern that is
basically the philosophy behind it yeah
yeah Thomas
too much for the internet a Cutting Edge
Technologies you want to dedicate one
third of the 15 billion to clean
Technologies and and clean deal projects
are you not worried that the member
states are not accompanying you anymore
in the green deal project and and how
money will be dedicated from the 15
billion you mentioned for clean tech
industry thank you so to take the last
part first it depends very much on the
projects that are in the pipeline but
looking at clean tech the clean tech
industry and the European green deal
vast support by the member states
because we should not forget that we've
just had the whole discussion on the
inflation reduction Act and the whole
world is engaging on Innovation and
Technologies for example in clean tech
because the whole world knows because of
climate change that if we want to
successfully fight climate change we
need these clean Technologies and those
who are the most Innovative and the most
advanced in these clean Technologies are
the Front Runners and will be the
exporter of the knowledge so it's a
highly competitive topic and therefore
there's a vast support by the member
states of What the clean tech industry
is concerned but I do not want to miss
to mention in the same Vein The Deep
Tech so the whole digitalization Quantum
Computing AI also a typical sector that
we're looking at and the biotech sector
Susanna
uh thank you on the your strategy I'd
like to understand because we see that
China already controls some strategic
strategic uh I'm thinking about for
instance the power grid in Portugal but
also in Italy or a Greece do you also
see a risk in here because I see that
you are recommending to review the
foreign investment uh regulations so do
you hope to see
changes here and if I make us today is
the world Refugee day don't you think
that Europe has been doing too little
seeing how how many people have died
recently in the Mediterranean thank you
so on the first topic um that is of
course here it would be a case-by-case
approach to look into what can be done
with the specific project we are
mentioning but overall
um so when we review the foreign direct
investment
regulation then um we will have with a
new regulation of view to the specific
projects Case by case
but in general for example the whole
topic up of dependency
um we have a 97 dependency uh what
lithium is concerned dependency on China
during my travel to Latin America
you are at the origin of lithium for
example in Argentina or in Chile
and it is wise to diversify our supply
chains away from the single
route to China for example also to
Argentina and to Chile because those
countries understand
and welcome that global gateway our
investment program for example for
critical raw materials has the principle
that the added value
stays in the country so we invest along
the whole value chain and that's for
them much more favorable than to having
the minerals extracted and moved to
China and they are processed and they
are the added value and then sold for
example to the European Union so this
all encompasses the whole topic of
um of Economic Security
migration
it is horrible what happened
and
um the more urgent is that we Act
um and there are two strands we're
working on the one is direct
concrete pragmatic action
for example the works together with
Tunisia to stabilize the country macro
financial assistance investment in their
economy here for example in renewable
energy
and on the other hand that we establish
a set of rules which is the migration
and Asylum pact so I'm glad it is
advancing because we need Among Us clear
rules for example that everyone coming
to the European border is treated
everywhere in the same manner
that we have also solidarity that all
the member states are caring for
refugees and people eligible for asylum
in and carry their fair share in the
financing of the support
thank you very much that's brings us to
the end of the VIP Corner we now move to
the press conferences thank you thank
you
foreign
[Music]